does this the michael boychuk salon and
the sterling club
are rewarding some of our local everyday
heroes with a day of pampering for all
they've done
throughout the pen dammit rocky is live
at the salon to help
show them off hey rocky
yes this is something so special that
the michael boyce salon
this is by the way michael boyce the man
himself celebrity hairstylist
stylist of the stars and to the heroes i
could add to your resume right
yeah we uh we want to do community
heroes in las vegas las vegas has
the best city in the world and you know
we've all been through some tough times
and there's
some people out there that are really
giving a lot and i call them heroes
and we want to have you nominate heroes
that you know
and we want to do makeovers for them i
love this concept so much so you can
come down to the michael boyce online at
the sterling club
and actually get your hair done make up
whatever you
was in the package that you went
secure manicure we're doing a little bit
of everything it's going to be designed
for the person and what they need
so if it's a guy that wins we have a
barber shop and we have one of the best
barbers anywhere so
we have it all got to come for anybody
right
okay so when people do come down how do
they get here what do they need to do
do they just how do they nominate their
friends and family well if you go to uh
sterling club at facebook or instagram
there's gonna be a form you fill out
okay and then there's gonna be a drawing
and and we're going to have people come
in
and it's so easy to get here you just
come down paradise you come straight in
you got ballet all right rocky we've got
to break away we are going to check in
with the
kova 19 press conference and governor
sissel act let's go to that now